let's return though to those
unprecedented strikes taking place in
the health service today with as many as
a hundred thousand nurses set to work
out joined by the health Minister Maria
Caulfield it's called lovely to see you
this morning
um
I I I suppose this must be a tricky one
for you you very very recently were back
in the wards yourself working as a nurse
you know that this will have been a very
very difficult decision for them and I
suspect that there is a bit of you that
that knows that they have something of a
point
yeah so I mean it's with huge regret
that we're seeing you know in England 44
of the 215 trusts uh going out on strike
today the same situation is in Wales
where all but one of the trusts there
are going out on strike in Northern
Ireland the government there are facing
all of their trusts so it is with regret
and absolutely we recognize that pay is
an issue that's why last year um nurses
were given a three percent pay rise with
no other public sector were and that's
why we accepted him for the
recommendation from the Independent pay
review body for this year of 4.8 percent
uh for most nurses but over nine percent
for those on the lowest bands
Steve Barkley we will talk about the
paid aspect in just a second but but
clearly people will be concerned about
service provision today and Steve
Barkley said that that he has concerns
about patients on a day like today where
exactly is he concerned what what areas
so I think also you know some of the the
national nurse leaders so Ruth May has
wrote to the RCN about concerns as well
and they were pleased that the r10 did
move on some of those uh uh derogations
for certain services but you know cancer
surgeries are going to be closed in
those 44 trusts in England we reckon
it's about 70 000 appointments
procedures surgeries uh that will be
lost so that is going to have an impact
when the system is already struggling to
get through the covert let's not mean so
what's here when you see have an impact
you are suggesting that as a result of
nurses going out on strike today
patients will suffer that people will be
in pain and that Health outcomes May
diminish well I think you know that that
is an inevitable action of strike action
um and that's why it is with regret um
that you know we see that the RCN are
going out uh on on action today
um you absolutely understand uh the
issues around paying I've explained uh
what measures we took around that but
the secretary of state did meet with the
RCN earlier this week to talk about some
of the other factors that make life uh
very difficult for nurses on the front
line if Steve Barkley had sat down this
week with the nurses and discussed P not
the other things but discuss P the
strikes would have not have gone ahead
today well I don't necessarily agree
with that we can't uh you think the RCN
were lying when they said if you sit
down with us and talk about P we will
not strike no I don't think that I don't
think that I know Pat Khan very well and
very a huge respect for for Pat I don't
think they were lying but the demand of
19 is not um uh something we can
realistically uh deliver on each of the
immediate perfectly cleared at the
weekend that yep they had suggested 19
but that they would be willing to
negotiate they would even perhaps have
been willing to take that figure of 7.5
which has worked in Scotland which is
why they do not have nurses striking so
in Scotland they they have suspended
strikes but that deal hasn't been agreed
they've put that to their members the
RCN aren't actually recommending that
deal to their members and we won't know
the outcome of that till the 19th of
December so they're not striking up
they're not striking today but they
haven't resolved the dispute in full and
we have for every percent that we agree
for the nurses or for anyone else uh in
fact that's around 700 million pounds
that we have to find and as a government
there's only three ways we can find that
money well I have to borrow it and we
know the impact of borrowing when
governments can't afford it we saw that
just a few weeks ago you either have to
put taxes up for patients for patients
and why not waste 30 billion pounds on
on useless PPE I mean the thing I don't
think many people understand here is why
this government is absolutely rigid in
its claim that it has to stick to the
recommendations of the independent peer
review body I mean you don't the
recommendations you've ignored it in
various other Industries I mean the
police Federation pulled out of their
independent remuneration review body
back in 2021 because for years the
government had ignored the
recommendations of that body on that
occasion it was politically expedient to
ignore it I'm generally suggesting that
on this occasion it is politically
expedient for you to let the strikes go
ahead well I disagree we did accept the
recommendations because we recognize
that pay is an issue and as I said
that's 4.8 for the average nurses but
over nine percent for those on on the
lowest bands so we absolutely uh
recognize that and committed to that in
full not just for nurses but across uh
the health recommendations in total
um yes we could uh you know they're not
legally binding we could uh override
that we freeze across the entire civil
service for a very long time that was
completely circumventing this
independent peer review body process
which exactly makes my point that you
know we could have uh ignored the pay
review bodies recommendations and gone
for a much lower pay rise we didn't we
could go higher but as I've said we've
got to find that money from somewhere
this isn't government money this is
taxpayers money
um and the three options open to us if
we were to to have to to fund a higher
pay rise is either to borrow the money
tax people more or take that money from
Frontline service or listen to the
former conservative party chairman Jake
Berry who says the government is going
to have to improve its offer I can tell
you Mr Berry said that the government
offer is too low I mean the period of
your body recommendation came back in
the summer when when inflation was was
lower you knew inflation was on the rise
if you'd actually negotiated back then
you could have probably gotten away with
seven and a half percent well the pay
review body also negotiate with the
unions the unions are involved in that
process and at that time they they did
not raise concerns you know as you say
you know it was no secret that inflation
was on the rise and they accepted that
at that time the process for April is
starting already and the unions will be
involved in that process in terms of
making their their um their position
clear about what they would like to see
in next year's pay Rises to just be
absolutely clear from now until January
when we are expecting no more strikes by
the Royal College of Nursing the
government point-blank refuses to sit in
a room with the head of the RCN and
discuss P not necessarily have an offer
but discuss P well the sales actually
did discuss pay with the RCN on Monday
we haven't come to an agreement on that
which is is quite clear because we have
said you know the Prime Minister was
very clear on prime minister's questions
yesterday that that's uh he's accepted
the pay review bodies recommendations we
can't go to 19 that's unrealistic the
labor government in Wales also haven't
moved on that so the RCN themselves have
said they are willing to come down from
19 I I mean I don't know why we keep
getting government figures saying as if
both of your positions aren't completely
interactable both of you can move so for
that we we are health is a devolved
matter as you know so we can only
negotiate for England but we're also
seeing trust uh all but one of the
trusts in labor-run Wales also uh out um
on strike and in Northern Ireland so you
know this is a similar situation in in
the other devolved Nations as well
um and so you know it's absolutely
crucial that we do keep the door open to
talks because we want to talk but we
cannot afford that 19
I do need to talk to you about about the
events that took place in the channel
yesterday and I think for a number of
people this is a situation that is
happening time and time again there are
an increased number of people coming
across the channel this year as we hear
from swella bravaman which means that
there is an increased risk of death
everything this government has tried to
do to prevent deaths in the channel has
not worked isn't it finally time for for
the conservative party for the
conservative government to admit that
you have field that you have failed to
prevent preventable deaths in the
channel well I think the Prime Minister
was very clear in his statement to the
House of Commons this week setting out
his five-point plan you know it's the
day before this terrible tragedy in the
channel and our heart goes out to all of
those involved and to the emergency
services that had to respond uh to that
terrible event but the Prime Minister
was very clear he doesn't feel that
progress has been good enough
um he's you know one of the things he's
highlighted is around clearing that
backlog by the end of uh next year
because it is taking too long to process
claims but also we do have to do more to
stop those Crossings across that is that
is the key point and I know I've got to
let you go in just a second but but
genuinely everything that this
government has tried has not worked
isn't it possibly time to to expand the
range of auctions try things that you
know this government for ideological
reasons has decided it could not push
forward such as or for example setting
up some ability for people to claim
Asylum without having to get in a small
boat and cross the channel so the Prime
Minister did that was one of his
recommendations as part of his plan to
to tackle this illegal immigration is to
open up safe illegal roots and he will
be having negotiations about that but
that is for genuine Asylum Seekers and
not for people who are coming here for
economic reasons and that's one part of
the whole process and he has said that
that's something he is looking at we'll
look forward to seeing what he has to
come up with I mean if you've got busy
days I'll let you go thanks thank you